[Music]
good ready for what's coming
[Music]
Jackson storm is part of the next
generation of high-tech racing buggy
sensations Jackson Stone Jackson storm
storm in a class of his own hey champ
got a good run you have no idea what a
pleasure it is for me to finally beat
you did you say meet or beat I think you
heard me enjoy your retirement
[Music]
you'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock kid but
you can wind it up again the racing
world is changing treadmills wind
tunnels virtual reality still working on
that and interactive race simulation
whoa I've jumped a barrier you have
crash we got some work to do I am so
excited that I get to train you
visualize beating
the beach ate me every week veteran
racers retire to make room for these
younger faster racers your questions
paparazzi
you'll never be as fast to storm but you
can be smarter
good luck out there you're gonna need it
I decide when I'm done
not winning this
gallon for you storm
[Applause]
[Music]